bon ben
- il a tout dit donc je
et
effectivement je suis une ancienne
étudiante de l'université de savoie
parce qu'à l'époque ça s'appelait comme
ça et je voulais juste vous raconter
cette histoire de boucles parce que je
viens de réintégrer l'université de
savoie
de l'autre côté du décor et c'est
vraiment l'itinéraire d'une sale gosse
puisque depuis toujours jean temps elle
fera jamais rien de sa vie celle là
c'est une
c'est une âme perdue ok c'est bon super
donc je commence du début tout petit
quand je suis entré à l'école à deux ans
est tout petit j'étais 12 g tonné
j'étais une enfant qui était curieuse
j'ai étonné et surtout j'ai beaucoup
dérangé inclassable ingérable
insupportable un rapport à l'autorité
assez compliqué c'est très drôle ou pas
donc l'école primaire ça s'est très bien
passé parce que j'habitais dans un petit
village ait été protégé et c'est là que
j'ai vraiment acquis mais de base et les
valeurs qui me porte encore aujourd'hui
ça a été heureusement qu'il ya eu savent
qu'après ça vraiment été beaucoup plus
compliqué donc là tout va bien on est
beaucoup en lien avec la nature on fait
plein de choses c'est génial on et 42
dans la même classe donc comme quoi
c'est possible aussi
voilà trois niveaux et là le drame
arrive le collège
là je pars au collège
et bien évidemment beaucoup de capacités
maîtrise les matières et n'en fait qu'à
sa tête
j'ai donc eu là quand même je suis assez
fier mon premier diplôme mon diplôme de
fumistes j'ai appris dernièrement que
c'est un métier j'ai des amis qui le
font ça rapporte pas mal et en plus ça
apporte de la chaleur au genre donc que
je trouve que finalement c'était bien
donc le collège voilà ça se passe pas
très bien c'est difficile on essaie
absolument me recadrer mais je veux rien
entendre
du coup une décision tranchée tombe on
va la mettre dans le privé en un terreau
là elle aura une très bonne éducation et
on va réussir à la faire rentrer dans le
moule et rien que le mot rentrer dans le
moule
c'était pour moi devenir une tarte c
était juste hors de question hors de
question donc je suis parti quand même
parce que j'avais pas le choix tu as
l'air l'internât alors là ça a été la
possibilité d'apprendre à m'adapter à à
ne rien lâcher et à travailler quand
même parce que là on n'avait jamais un
peu moins de choix que c'est très très
stricte
donc après je m'en vais et là je me dis
moi je veux faire qu'une chose c'est de
l'anglais et je ne vois là c'est de
l'anglais de l'anglais de l'anglais et
je voulais devenir enseignante
parce que j'avais envie le fond du fond
c'était de changer le regard auprès des
jeunes est de pouvoir renseigner d'une
nouvelle façon donc j'arrive au lycée je
continue la faille du système s'est tant
qu on se maintient au dessus de 10 donc
on peut continuer il n'y a pas de
problème donc quand on est un peu
intelligent ont fait le minimum syndical
et tout se passe bien
du coup j'ai mon bac grâce à l'anglais
la philo et le russe étaient les trois
seules matières qui m'intéressait elles
ont j'arrive à l'université de savoie
toute contente je vais faire de
l'anglais en 6e anglais
j'ai fait de l'anglais beaucoup
d'anglais donc de glissance et puis je
me dis non en fait l'enseignement j'ai
pas envie ça m'intéresse pas peut-être
parce que je me suis dit aussi si c'est
fait j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit si je
dois me farcir des gosses comme moi tous
les jours
non je pas envie donc j'ai tout arrêté
et je suis parti avec mon sac à dos dans
le monde puisque toute façon comme
j'étais une âme perdue quand on ferait
jamais rien de moi je me suis dit foutu
pour foutu je vais aller voir ce qui se
passe ailleurs
donc leur angoisse de mes parents il va
lui arriver des trucs elle est tout seul
donc tous les pays on sait pas ce
qu'elle fait voilà ce qu'à l'époque il
n'y avait pas internet
je sais ça vous parle pas du tout on
avait encore des téléphones avec des
fils au bout et des cabines
téléphoniques on mettait des pièces ou
des cartes
donc voilà ça ça m'a donné une ouverture
d'esprit incroyable une richesse de
rencontre plein plein plein de choses et
ça a été très facilité par l'anglais
d'où la cohérence vous avez juste voir
qu'en fait notre vie c'est ça que j'ai
envie de vous dire notre vie est un
puzzle et dès que la pièce maîtresse
tombe c'est fascinant de voir avec
quelle logique vous avez avancé et et
que tous les choix vous avez fait malgré
tout ce que vous avez pu entendre c'est
des choix personnel que vous avez écouté
et donc assumer parce que ça aussi c'est
important et qui sont complètement
logique et ça c'est vraiment ce que je
vous souhaite de pouvoir voir ça prend
des fois un peu de temps il ya
effectivement des chemins de traverse à
prendre c'est en se trompant qu'on
apprend c'est en osant et en allant vers
qu'on apprend
voilà osé c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure
parce que tout ce que vous risquez c'est
un nom et ça c'est pas grave donc au
bout d'un moment j'ai fait la globe
trotter super génial je reviens en
france et là je me dis qu'est-ce que je
vais faire
en fait je n'ai pas envie de faire moi
j'avais envie d'être
c'est quand même assez compliqué parce
qu'être ça fait pas manger donc j'ai dit
ok je vais aller travailler
je trouve un boulot comme pendant mes
études j'avais eu un job aussi je
retourne dans le même job donc grande
distribution il me reprenne tout de
suite
et là je me dis ok super mais j'ai pas
envie de rester là donc j'ai gravi au
fur et à mesure toutes les marches de la
hiérarchie jusqu'à devenir responsable
de magasin et à avoir une spécialité de
nettoyeurs ce qui a fait que j'allais
remonter les magasins de la france
entière qui ne fonctionnait pas donc ça
c'était des challenge et moi j'avais
besoin d'un challenge et de nouveautés
en permanence sinon je m'ennuie très
vite 15 déménagement quinze ans ça ça
donne de l'agilité la flexibilité et
encore et encore des rencontres i péri
au bout de 15 ans j'en ai eu marre j'en
ai eu marre aussi parce que j'ai eu mes
enfants et que la grande direction a dit
j'ai voulu ne plus travailler le samedi
et on m'a dit non faut choisir entre le
travail et les enfants
j'avais déjà fait mes enfants je pouvais
pas les jeter donc j'ai choisi
d'arrêter ce travail là en tout cas donc
ok on arrête et l'a commencé à germer
des questions sur les jeunes les enfants
et la parentalité c'est un métier
hyperimportant l'apprend pas comment on
est un bon parent comment on fait avec
nos enfants
ok donc ça c'est en coin tête je décide
de revenir une fois avoir sillonné toute
la france de revenir en savoie parce que
c'est là où il ya le plus d'énergie je
pense est le plus de dynamisme qui me
restait de va qui me tient à coeur parce
que je veux pouvoir rester découle donc
je reviens ici et comme j'avais arrêté
donc la grande distribution mais quand
même beaucoup d'expérience
professionnelle je décide de monter une
boîte parce que je reste quand même
mine de rien entrepreneurs sse
qu'entrepreneur ça veut dire prendre en
main et toujours j'ai pris les choses en
main pour avancer
en dépit de plein de chose qui
dérangeait beaucoup de monde donc voilà
je crée une société de a à z
donc là c'est le commercial les arrache
la comptabilité faut tout faire en fait
faut être polyvalent
je monte petit à petit et j'arrive à une
équipe de 17 personnes puisque ce que je
préfére avant tout c'est le management
la relation aux autres donc je crée ça
en même temps
j'attaque une nouvelle formation dont je
reprends des études à 40 ans et je vais
me former pour devenir
alors coach je déteste ce mot et c'est
pour ça que j'ai créé le métier de
possibilités je fais tout un parcours
pour avoir l'équivalent d'un master en
communication parce que c'est important
d'avoir un master afin d'avoir un
diplôme en france
et voilà je continue et je fais ça en
parallèle de la société que j'ai créée
la société que j'ai créée au bout de dix
ans j'avais fait le tour je m'ennuie je
m'en vais et là je monte mon autre
entreprise sur l'accompagnement à la
parentalité comment on fait pour devenir
parents et l'accompagnement auprès des
jeunes
tout ça ça a évolué et évoluent et
évoluer ça s'est construit les pièces se
sont mises au fur et à mesure et
dernièrement donc je découvre et je
décide en tant que sales gosses bien sûr
de créer mon métier de possibilités
parce qu'elle est pas de mots dans
toutes les cases qui existait dans
lesquels on a toujours voulu mettre pied
qui me correspondait et là je me
spécialise dans les adolescents 15 25
ans et je décide de mettre tout en
oeuvre tout le réseau que j'ai construit
qui est très important et multi
directionnelle pour le mettre au service
de la réalisation de vos rêves de vos
projets et de tout ce que vous avez
envie de faire ça s'est étendu à toutes
les personnes qui sont en reconversion
professionnelle parce que aujourd'hui la
question du sens est fondamental et il
ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont en
perte de sens donc mon métier c'est ça
c'est ce que je fais tous les jours et
j'ai eu la chance
dernièrement d'être rappelé par
l'université savoie mont blanc puisque
c'est maintenant comme ça qu'elle
s'appelle et j'ai été recruté pour vous
dire l'ouverture quand même de notre
université en tant que possibilit sts en
tant que manager pour réformer tout le
premier cycle universitaire et le
problème réformes du premier cycle
universitaire c'est remettre les jeunes
au centre et au coeur de leur parcours
et faciliter la possibilité de découvrir
plein de choses
donc si vous voyez bien et je vous
laisse juge de la boucle qui vient
d'être bouclée toujours les jeunes du
management est le fait des tournées vers
les autres en permanence
donc j'ai réalisé mon rêve j'ai envie de
le mettre au service de tout le monde de
montrer que c'est possible parce que oui
tout est possible merci
[Applaudissements]